our first guest is one of the hardest
working women in hollywood
you can catch her in the netflix movie a
week away the abc
show calling your mother and co-hosting
the podcast two funny mamas
please welcome the hilarious sherry
shepherd
[Music]
wow i'm so
happy angry
what is hap you look amazing girl thank
you i'm so nervous because this is the
first time i've ever worn this outfit
it's been my goal out amazing about it
thank you that barn door open and i'm
still standing
we're still standing we haven't sat down
yet this is what happens when you let go
of an ex-husband i'm gonna let you know
that
when does that happen it happens that
does not happen
yes yes it will i'm here to promise you
that
i was like i'm looking for that adele
plan
when does that happen um no what
inspired you you already looked
beautiful so what inspired you to just
trim down
my um you know what i have to say when
jeffrey you know my son jeffrey
he uh he's got a special needs and he
was sitting in the car and i was eating
like a candy bar
yeah and he said mommy if you die who's
going to be my bodyguard
that's what he said oh and i said what
and he said
if you are not here who's going to take
care of me and it
literally hit me like jerry you got to
change your life
so this is that's my baby and this is my
third year with no sugar
wow and i i stopped eating pork and beef
and dairy because i said i want to be
healthy yeah for jeffrey now the perk is
i get to put on this little vichy
bodysuit
there you go and you put it on it looks
so good that door opened i was like i'm
so angry
thank you i am like what in the world
with the dress
yes this is my birthday photo shoot
because i turned
54. what yes 54 y'all
what but i just
you know it's like i wanted to show
people i don't like share anymore
look at you i just wanted to show people
that
you know you you're not counted out
because sometimes people hollywood is
not kind to you
as you get older and i wanted to show
people you still got it or society in
general
or society yeah so this is like my
health journey this was the perk in my
health journey wow and i wanted to pay
homage to like
you know glam hollywood dorothy
dandridge and lena horn and diane
carroll so that's
my photo shoot that i did jesus take the
wheel you look amazing
um so this is your fourth time here so
since you look so fabulous um
our every time someone has been here
four times we give them a little present
you're going to look real good and
that's what's going on
maybe get you the smallest guys
[Applause]
i have a convertible so i can put this
on in my convertible car oh my god and
drive i'm a little cute girl and i'm
manifesting a date
and my team kelly jackson jacket yes
baby
yes all right so your your friend and
two funny mom is co-host kim whitley
she's also been here four times
and i hear that are you each other's
like emergency contact like in case of
an earthquake
girl the last earthquake the last two
earthquakes that happened i called kim
up and i was so scared because i'm
traumatized from earthquakes
because the big one that we had back in
1995
somewhere around there i was on a booty
call and that was the worst
because i thought that jesus christ was
coming it was like boom boom
and i realized oh my gosh jesus is
coming he gonna knock on my door i'm
gonna booty call with somebody i don't
even like first of all
so i made him get on the floor we were
butt naked and we were praying for
forgiveness through the whole earthquake
i was so traumatized so that's all i
remember
is being on a booty call earthquakes
mean booty call bad booty call
so i'm just like so whenever we have an
earthquake i call up kim
and i'm like you just got to walk me
through this girl whoo
i don't like them i have to pretend
because i have little kids right so i
have to pretend that everything's fine
i'm like it's going to be great it's
going to be great like it's still
shaking and i'm like
and i run to their bedrooms whatever and
anyway they they i have to act like i'm
not freaked out but i'm freaked out
because don't freaking hurt this movie
jeffrey is he he's 16 so he sleeps
through earthquakes
but i'm always afraid that i'm gonna
wake up and i ain't gonna have no
clothes on so you gotta have your
earthquake closed
so as soon as it starts shaking and it
ain't your boobs shaking you gotta run
and grab the clothes and put it on you
know this is true
tmi but like i generally like
sleeping naked i don't like i get hot i
don't like it you know whatever
am i but you can't do that in this state
because
i know that my ass will be caught
they'll some firefighter have to come
get me out of my roof caving in and i'll
just be sitting there in the bus well
that's what you want as a firefighter to
see you butt naked girl maybe after i've
been on your plan but right now it'd be
a little much
like i don't know you're welcome mom so
you are the musical
on netflix it's called a week away so
did you like doing the singing and
dancing are you terrified
you know i can't sing kelly i can't sing
i can't dance i was voted off the mass
singer i was voted off dancing how did
you land a job where you're singing and
dancing if you can't do either no i
think it's my sheer personality
force of will that did it but you know
the way they wait they had me sing like
i admire you kelly
they had me go in the studio and sing
each word
and then they strung the best of
together
yeah they edited in auto i sound like a
black pat benatar
that's what i said anyway because it was
like ah open
open up up and they just took everything
and put it together the bible the bible
the level
and then that i sounded like pat
bennett's house oh my god i love you so
much right now
because it does sound funny when they
edit and it's a different energy as well
from a different take
and you'd be like intimate then i heard
it and i was like oh my god so when i
come back on can we do like a duet can
we just like proud mary yes
or something but i want to do it like
weird edited version
this is what our edit was exactly people
don't it's a real thing
but you recently had a birthday and
that's to me i did too so how did you
celebrate
i celebrated my birthday kim whitley she
is one of us she has a tennis court
in her backyard so we do whitley on
wheels it's a skating
week she calls it whitley on wheels and
it's our own private skating rink
and so she threw me we do that
absolutely and that's what we do we
skate this is her tennis court and we
just skate
for her tennis court and i love it
because kim doesn't skate
she just rides her bike around the court
oh
yeah she screams and she goes hey it's
duet
it's men and women skating and so it's a
skating party
that she threw me for my birthday
because i love roller skating
that's awesome my whole thing i always
say is it's a couple skit like it's like
yeah because that was the time i
generally get off this the floor oh you
buy yourself no
you know like in like junior high when
you're like cool um i'll just be
i was i won some nachos anyway see when
you go to adult skate like you got to
come over kim's house okay
when it's couple skating we don't have
anybody to skate with it we get a shot
of tequila
with our shout out to kids we're just
skating around yeah it makes you feel
good done
you don't know you about yourself i'll
tell you that
you're with everyone so how did you
learn to roller skate why did you do
that
i started you know what because roller
skating is such a culture in the african
american community i saw 70 year old
skating and 90 year old skating
at the rink and so danielle hawkins who
she came and she was teaching me how to
roller skate so we go to a park
and we skate on the basketball court
that's danielle and it's so funny
because all the teenagers would sit
there in the swings and laugh at me
but i realized even when they were
laughing at me i said but i'm actually
trying it
like that's the difference between a
dream and a reality you make it happen
so now when they see me they're like go
ahead mama
go ahead auntie yeah so it's so great
and i feel
free when i roller skate it's fun it's
so much it kind of makes you feel like a
child at heart again
like salute yeah and i don't want to
break anything so there's that
fear it's funny how you fear nothing
when you're a kid and you're doing those
things and now i'm just like
wait so if i break this and i won't be
able to do that job and i won't be able
to that's what you think because you
know the hips don't have the bounce back
like when we were 12. and i'm always
like this
and you you got to know that you're
going to fall but when you fall you get
back up
that's what it is everything so um you
also started pole dancing
yes i was talking about this so how are
the lessons going the lessons are going
slow but it's go they're going because
you know
well danielle hawkins who is also my
pole dancer she also pole dances with
skates on by the way
yeah but she always the moves that she
has me doing i'm like girl i got
arthritis and that part of my leg and
this
inflammation the inflammation but she'll
say like now we're going to bring our
legs up and i go with what muscles
and muscles i ain't got that so i'm i'm
going through but
it works your abs your core your arms
muscles you didn't even know you had
muscles you didn't even know you had
dude i tried once
and this hotel randomly had a pole in it
look it was a bunch of people wasn't
freaky like that but there's nothing
wrong with it you wouldn't be pretty
like that
but i just mean i travel and i it the
loudest
it was just like it was like and this
was when i was in shape and
i got on it and just boof wait what i
was like
you tried too hard i'm gonna tell you i
went and did a movie in vancouver for a
lifetime
and i brought you can take the pole with
you i have a pole in my bedroom wait
it's a travel pole yes it's travel pole
i have it in my bedroom jeffrey came in
the room he said
i wouldn't have my daughter doing this
and i was just like what
so this is in canada but i didn't put it
up right
and so the asbestos all fell from the
ceiling in my mouth
but it was so funny to see the canadian
police because they were like what is
this and i said it's my
poll and they said what do you what is
it for and i said it's when i dance and
they going why are you here i said i'm
doing a movie
so i think they thought i was doing a
porno it was all right my god
oh my god i love that explanation to
people showing up
it's my dance phone it's amazing yup i'm
still here
just waiting for you to subscribe if you
don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever help